[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hey, everybody. Welcome
to our hallway chat.
I haven't come up with
a final name for this,
but this is our experiment
to see if you all like these.
But my thought process here
is how some people say their
favorite part of conferences
are those conversations they
get to have in the hallway,
and when you get to
talk with someone about something you
just learned, or how
it applied to you,
or maybe something you wish
a presentation covered.
So in one of our
Data Science Hangouts in early November,
somebody had asked,
are you ever asked to
estimate the ROI, Return On Investment,
from an analytics project
before the business is willing
to invest in anything?
And a shout out to
Nick who asked that.
I'm not sure if Nick's
actually here on the call now.
But how do you approach that?
And so there was a lot of
conversation about this in the
chat, and people wanting to talk
more about it. So here we are.
I
posted on LinkedIn to see who
would be open to sharing their
process for this,
and we'd love to introduce
two leaders joining us today.
They'll both share their thoughts
to kick off the conversation.
But this is a group discussion
about all things ROI, to share
ideas and our own experiences
to help each other.
Like the Data Science Hangouts,
it's totally OK to
just listen in here.
But if you have follow up
questions on the topic or want
to provide your own perspective
on what's worked or hasn't
worked, there's a few
ways you can contribute.
So you can raise your
hand here on Zoom.
And just to tell people how
if you're not familiar with that,
in the bar below,
there's a reactions button.
And from there, you
can raise your hand.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a star next to it if it's
something you want me to
read out loud instead.
Maybe you're in a coffee
shop or something.
And then lastly, we
have a Slido link,
which I will share
here in the chat
in just a second.
But you can ask
questions anonymously there as well.
And thank you to somebody who
just said I need to switch my
background because it needs
to mirror the Posit logo.
It's showing OK on my side.
I put a virtual background
because I'm at my parents house
and was hiding everything behind
me. Did that last minute.
But just to let everybody
know, like the Data Science Hangouts,
this session will be recorded.
So if you want to go
back and listen again,
I'll be sure to share
that to the Posit YouTube.
But before jumping in, just
a reminder, we're all dedicated
to making our community events
a welcoming environment for everybody.
We love hearing from everybody
no matter your years of experience,
the languages that you work
in, titles, or industry.
But with all of that,
thank you so much for
spending time with us today.
I'd love to introduce
both Joe Powers,
principal data scientist at
Intuit, and Derek Beaton,
director of advanced analytics
at Saint Michael's Hospital.
Do you both want to maybe
kick things off by just sharing a
little bit with us about each
of your roles and kind of say
hello before we dive into ROI?
- Sure, Derek, you
want to lead off?
- Sure, thanks.
So I'm Derek, director
of advanced analytics
in a unit at St. Michael's
Hospital in Toronto.
Our unit is data science
and advanced analytics.
We are an applied
health care unit.
So we put
stats and now AI tools
into production for mostly clinical use.
But there are quite a few
operational or like staffing
solutions that we
put into place.
We're not research.
It's all about getting things actually
done and into the hands of users.
Overall, our group
is about 30 people.
We technically work
across three hospitals--
St. Michael's, St.
Joseph's, and Providence,
all in Toronto as part of
the Unity Health Network.
We are mostly in
our house. We have
maybe 70% of our
solutions in are.
And then we've got a
variety of things in Python,
including some new stuff
we've recently launched
with a little bit of
stuff in, pretty much any
sort of analytics, AI and
ML domain. So imaging,
clinical prediction, patient flow,
forecasting, you name it,
we probably do a
little bit of it.
- Awesome. Joe, you
want to go next?
JOE: Yeah, sure.
So, yeah, I'm Joe
Powers. I work at Intuit.
You're probably familiar with
some of our flagship products
like QuickBooks,
TurboTax, Mailchimp.
And, yeah, so
I lead experimentation, which
is a huge amount of ROI
involved in it, largely around
investigating new methods for how
we could run faster and
more accurate AB tests
for product and marketing decisions.
And so when you move
the whole company, you're
shifting their decision-making process
to a new statistical method.
People want to know. Like
why is the juice going to be
worth the squeeze on this? And so,
yeah, when Rachael
brought this topic up,
I was I was happy to join in.
Because
I feel like it's one
of those hidden curricula topics that
like it's central to doing your
job as a data scientist. But
absolutely no one
teaches this. So, good
for you for being here today.
- So I was thinking we jump
in and get started with sharing
a little bit about how you both
have approached this.
And then people can jump
in with questions and thoughts, too.
I know you both have
very different approaches to this, too.
And it's really cool to see
the difference across industries as well.
I don't know who wants to
get started. But I was thinking maybe
kind of giving us a baseline
and sharing a little bit about
what you do.
Derek,
do you want to maybe start
with explaining how the process your
teams rolled out?
- Sure, yeah.
And in some ways, maybe
this will feel really specific.
But
it's because we're in
health care in a hospital.
But I think a lot of this
is pretty generalizable. So,
and I'll share a document or part
of a document with us in a
moment. So when
a project comes our way,
it usually comes from
someone on the ground,
so a physician or someone in HR
or say a clinical manager in some way.
They have a problem, they
know data can solve it.
And they work with a
few of us in the team,
primarily the directors
and the product managers
on filling out and detailing
project intake form.
And one of the most
critical parts of the project intake
form, which I will--
Rachael, am able to share?
- Yes, I will just make
you a co-host so that you're able
to. And I got rid
of my Posit logo,
which was backwards in
the background. And now, I'm in
a fancy boardroom here for this
ROI conversation.
DEREK: Awesome.
- One second. I'll make
you co-host. There you go.
- Awesome, thank you. So
I'll just do this real fast,
and you can take away my
co-host abilities in a moment.
RACHAEL: You can keep them.
I just didn't want everybody
to be able to screen share.
- So
as part of that project intake,
there's a key section
here called evaluation metrics.
And right off the bat, you
should have a good idea
of whether you're trying to
address mortality, admission,
length of stay, financial
issues, or human
effort, generally,
across the types of problems
you want to solve in the
hospital. There's
another box, other,
which is usually an indicator
of like we probably aren't
going to take this on or it's
hard to define or hard to measure.
But a lot of these are
generally easier to track or
measure and assess the impact.
And from there,
we work with our collaborators on
how to define the primary metric.
So are you trying to do
something to reduce a length of stay?
Then we are going to look
at how to do that as well as
tracking the actual length of
stay pre and post deployment. And
when we do this,
we have discussions early on
about what the expected level
of change is.
So if you think you can bring
length of stay down for,
say, all patients
in a certain unit by
let's say, 30 minutes
in an ICU or something.
So you bring the overall
down quite a bit.
We'll get this
written down here,
and that's how we proceed
and measure and assess things
when it's after the fact.
I'll stop sharing now.
But we have a fairly
deep and detailed discussions at this
intake stage about
what the metrics are,
how we're going to measure it,
how we're going to track it,
and what the level of change
is expected to be. And a lot
of the expectation will come from
knowing the hospital or the system
in general,
knowing the types of changes
that do exist in other sites
where you can point to
literature or something else
somewhere else. And say look,
they saw a 10% reduction,
so we would expect
about the same.
So a lot of this is based
off of targeting something,
identify a key health economics
metric, and let's work
out how much we think we're
going to actually make a
difference. If things aren't say
a huge benefit or if they
fall in that other box,
this is where we say like,
maybe we're not going to take
this on or we have to dig
really deep into the types
of things that might yield value
overall for either the unit,
the hospital, the system,
like the whole network of ours,
before considering
taking it on.
So we get pretty deep into
this on how we actually
assess and decide what to
do before we fully commit.
As part of this where we
won't necessarily like--
Rachael, so I guess
to one of your points,
like before any commitment. There
is some commitment we have
or that we'll get into. So
if people come to us,
and they're like, yeah,
I think we can get this
measure here, here, here,
and we want to get a baseline.
We'll absolutely work with anyone
to establish what those baselines are.
So that part comes with
the project intake.
It's just the deciding to
move into the full development of
something is really where we
need to see what that baseline
is and really dig into what
these improvements are going to be.
- And I'm sorry if
you said this already,
but how long have you had that
process in place with the intake form?
- Quite a while.
The intake form here has been
revised as recently as a little
over a year ago.
But those metrics have been
in place pretty much since
the start of this group,
which predates me.
So always trying to target
big health economics type metrics.
- Well I was just asking in
the chat. I was curious for people
listening in if you
have something similar to that,
like a project intake form.
And if so,
what some of those evaluation
metrics might be for you.
Maybe a good reminder, I
should have said up front.
But I love to see everybody
talking in the chat and during
these sessions, too.
If you've been to
a Data Science Hangout before,
you might see a lot of
resources get shared in the
chat. So feel free to use that
during the session, too.
Joe, do you want to
share a little bit--
JOE: Yeah, sure.
- --with us about what you do?
-
I think just kind of echo some
key things that Derek said
around like identifying
those key metrics.
A lot of people talk
about stakeholders.
I tend to think
about gatekeepers.
You have lots of
stakeholders, but really,
thinking now about which ones
are the gatekeepers that are
going to block or allow
your project to roll out.
So like what are the
metrics that they really care about?
And yeah, establishing
baseline. There's
very likely a dashboard
that those leaders are regularly
referring to that you can
anchor to as a shared reality.
And then what is a
reasonable lift that you could expect?
That could be based
on literature review.
It could be
based on qualitative testing.
If you looked at 20 users in
UX settings, and you said, oh, our
invoice completion rate went from
20% to 90% with the new
invoice flow.
That is actually a great anchor
point that you could now start
thinking about. Like, OK,
that's in an idealized setting.
But when it moves into
the product, like,
what's reasonable to expect?
So a lot of times,
you're just dealing with
the best data or best
information you can
get your hands on.
And that can run
the gamut from maybe
it was captured in your data
lake to running a few surveys
or doing some qualitative
sessions. But any
information is
better than none.
So, yeah, key metrics,
baselines, reasonable lift. And
then, actually,
that's where for me,
it becomes a data
simulation task after that.
And I'm happy to share a
little bit because like I said,
nobody ever taught
me how to do this,
but it's just
become like my go-to
for the workflow.
So
I'm in our studio right
now, and I've loaded the tidyverse.
And so you can imagine, yeah,
my baseline is this rate A.
So maybe I have a 50%
rate. Maybe this is like
a conversion rate or a click
rate, whatever is that key
metric for your gatekeepers. And
maybe I'm just going to explore
some like reasonable lift.
Like maybe I think I could lift
this a tenth of a percent with
some new program.
OK, I've got 100,000
customers, and I'm going to run
4,000 simulations. So,
yeah, I can execute
this now in this cell.
So I'm using the
binomial distribution.
If you're not familiar or
you're not comfortable using
these likelihood functions,
I think this is something
just really worth leaning into. Like
a lot of abstract
statistics become really concrete and
intuitive once you get
comfortable simulating data
with likelihood functions.
So all I'm doing here is I'm
running 4,000 simulations
with 100,000 trials. And I
can set the probability of
success on each trial.
And this is going to output
like a tally of events.
But then once I divide
that by the population,
I'll always get a rate.
So maybe this outputs
50,000 events.
But when that divides by 100,000,
now, I get a 50% rate. OK.
So
I could actually just
give you a peek at-- give
you a sense of
[INAUDIBLE].
So, yeah, for my first
simulation, I have 50.1%.
The second one, 50.2.
I hope this is getting clearer.
I tried to keep this minimal.
- Would you--
like this now, would you
be able to describe what's
a project that you might be working
on where you would be doing this?
- So
you could think of--
this is really very close to
the idea of a power analysis.
If you were introducing
this 0.1% improvement, you could
start asking questions like, how
likely are we to detect it?
And so,
even in this case, if I just
look at how often are my
B simulations bigger
than my A simulations?
That's not saying it's
statistically significant.
It's just saying bigger at all.
It's this small of a change
100,000 users. 68% of the time,
it would it larger.
And you could explore like
the range of differences that you
might observe like
a 95% interval
of those potential differences.
The very concrete examples that I
could give are like when I'm exploring
a new AB testing method.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to simulate the test data from
100,000 AB tests.
And then I can start
asking very practical questions from
those simulated data.
Like how often did I detect
the superior
treatment condition?
How long did it take
to detect the superior treatment condition?
How many additional conversions
did we yield because we
detected the better experience
earlier and rolled it out
to 100% earlier in the season?
Those are the kind of return
on investment questions that I can
explore using very basic
data simulation that my
gatekeepers, my stakeholders
really care about.
They want to know before
they greenlight using
a new statistical
method in season.
They're going to want to know,
does this detect benefit
more often and faster?
Does it detect harm
And
this is all just--
that initial return
on investment research,
they're going to want to the
same thing on the tail end of
the project about how
well this lived up to
your projections.
But I just wanted to show
this as using these likelihood functions.
In NumPy, you have
available in Base-R.
But they're very powerful
and very persuasive when you're
trying to do like ROI
sizing for a new project.
RACHAEL: Oh, that's
great. Thank you.
And
thinking about that,
the ROI that you showed
there, how do you
translate that into
communication with the business
stakeholders? Is it through
like a business case document?
- Through all
means possible. So it's,
again,
as I mentioned,
gatekeepers earlier.
Like thinking about
who's approval? Who's buying,
and you need for a
project to get greenlit?
That person is going to have
a lot of people demanding their
attention. They've got a lot
of fires to put out. Like,
how are you going to get your idea
in front of them so that it sticks?
You give a 20-minute
presentation.
20 minutes later, they're
probably only going to--
if you succeeded,
they're only going to remember
one or two things from that
presentation. And so the
clarity of your communication--
and we had a former CEO
who loved the expression,
"Repetition doesn't
sully the prayer." Just
repeat, repeat, repeat.
And just keep driving home
that central message that appeals to
them, like if they
have an urgent problem,
and you're offering the
solution, if you're doing it
clearly, you're not going to have
to offer it that many times.
But be ready to deliver.
And
so, anyhow, but yeah,
through communication,
it's like start sending word
out in Slack channel, offer
I guess more peer-supportive
trainings through Zoom meetings
and live meetings, get
your peers on board,
work through your
manager to get
face time in--
there's usually a recurring
executive presentations,
where you can get in
front of your leaders to pitch
your potential solutions.
And if you're coming in there,
not only with the
performance of your solution,
but the return on investment in
a metric they care about and recognize,
like this is just all stuff
that greases the skids to make
sure that your project gets
a mandate and goes into practice.
And like we said earlier,
just be ready on the tail
end to verify that you delivered
what you promised. Because
that really kind of like puts
a bow on it and really cements
the relationship that in the
future it's just going to be
that much easier for you
to get that face time,
to get the approval to put
your projects into production.
- Definitely.
George, you asked a question
in the chat a bit earlier.
Do you to jump in here?
GEORGE: OK, yeah.
Sorry, I'm battling a cold,
and my voice is pretty terrible.
Yeah, I was wondering how
you would estimate or measure your
own time investment.
Because I think the other
half of this equation is
understanding how much effort
it will take for you to
do that. And also, how
accurate those estimates are?
- I have only seen that
"accurately" measured
with survey data.
I've tried to use calendar data
for these kind of projects.
It is meaningless.
The loyalty of people to
their calendars, the accuracy,
the coding, just don't even
try it would be my advice.
But just asking like a good
survey question about in
the past week--
like surveying
analysts, for instance,
or surveying the key people.
Like in the past week,
how much time did you spend
on like these parts of your work?
Is that a typical week?
But usually it helps to anchor.
Like anchoring surveys to a
specific time period can really
improve the accuracy
of responses. But honestly,
just survey data
is the only thing
to answer your question that
I think that's the best signal.
It's not great, but I think
it's the best you can do.
- Derek, do you want
to add anything there?
- Yeah, so estimating
ahead of time,
we don't.
It's really hard
to make a guess,
especially when a
lot of stuff we do is
pretty variable and unknown,
especially in the early start--
like parts of the projects.
Measuring later,
we're probably a little bit
better about once we're like
really in the weeds.
And this would come a lot
from our product managers and the
way we've set up
our sprint cycles.
We got a pretty good track of--
or at least within
good like small windows.
We have a pretty good sense
of what we're doing and how much
effort we're putting into
the respective projects.
But that's definitely
not something we--
I would say estimate very far
in advance, so like at the ROI
project intake stage,
more so like in the project is this
going to take you a week, two weeks,
one day stuff like that.
But
I think where maybe
that question,
if I were to make
a guess, George,
is this about trade off?
Like how many person hours
is it really going to take?
Is it going to take three,
four years for something to
happen and maybe that cancels
out some of the ROI
from the project?
GEORGE: Yeah, exactly.
If it's going to take you,
let's say, eight months
to make this tenth of a percent
increase, is that worth it? I mean,
and then other factors, well,
maybe in a couple of years, we
know things will change.
So maybe that tenth of a
percent isn't even going to
last us that long because
things will change,
and then alter that, so.
- Yeah,
I didn't use tenth of a percent
because it's like a good
target. I used tenth
of a percent just
because I was writing
this five minutes ago.
But
you should have, obviously--
I think a lot of times
the benefit needs to just be
unquestionably worth
the time investment.
GEORGE: Yeah.
- It
often just doesn't come up
because it's just so obviously--
the
reward to investment ratio is
should be high enough that it's
just not a hang up. If
it is getting that marginally close,
it's probably not something to
pursue. Because let's face it,
most ideas fall flat.
GEORGE: Yeah, I guess
I'm kind of really
interested in this
question because
we have a small data science team,
and we get a lot of different--
we have a lot of needs. We
have a lot of requests. And we
support the lab
at GPL or we got a
lot of different needs, but we
also just have very focused areas.
So we kind of have
to run things through like, well,
does this support the vision?
Our vision statement here,
does it support the
strategy but also--
yeah, we have 10 projects
that are great ideas,
but which of those 10
would be the best ROI?
Would have the best ROI?
So it's all about I
think for me competing priorities, so
with a limited amount
of resources we have.
- I have found it
really helpful,
like as I've gotten more
into Bayesian statistics
this idea of a
prior probability, particularly around success.
And this
to me maps exactly
with your question.
It's like you have multiple
potential projects you could
pursue. And it's like,
you and your stakeholders are
like really the experts in this
space at the company.
Put a prior probability
of success around it.
What is the range of
outcomes that, going into the project,
it might realize? It might
manifest, that is. And then,
I think that could be
enormously helpful in helping
you decide, is this something
we should explore more,
or is this something that's
like promising enough that like
it's time to go do it?
But again, I think prior to
my getting
into Bayesian statistics,
that idea would not have been
as clear to me that like, oh,
I could actually go into a
project. And I always do, in fact,
go into projects with a
prior estimate of how successful it's
likely to be what the range of
effect sizes I might reasonably expect are.
I just wasn't making
it explicit before I learned
Bayesian statistics.
But it's hugely important. If
everything you do has a
low prior probability of success,
you're just generating noise, so.
GEORGE: That is helpful.
I appreciate that. Thanks.
- I'd love to--
someone just about
to ask a question.
WOMAN: I was, I can't figure
out how to raise my hand today.
RACHAEL: Go ahead.
WOMAN: I'm so sorry about that.
Have you guys ever run
into an issue where
you have to make a change
because maybe it's compliance
or legal and you still have
to then estimate like the amount
of time it's going to
take to do that, where the
return on investment is
not necessarily like--
there may be dollars
saved to do this,
but you also
are legally required to
make those changes.
And so then,
you have to plan out your
project from that perspective.
I know working with hospitals,
there's a lot of compliance
regulations and so curious
how you guys approach those
kinds of requests.
-
If we have to make a
change within one of our own projects
that we make the change.
There's no discussion really about how
long is this going to take?
Or what is the return here
because we've already got the
return or know what the return
is or has been from that
project or that initiative.
So in the case of
something where it's like compliance or
security or critical upgrade,
we're just going to do it.
There's no question about it
WOMAN: Yeah, I've
run into issues where
we're trying to do something
because it's a potential
compliance thing.
And so you get into that hairy
thing where it's like, OK,
well, maybe it's fine,
but maybe it's not fine.
And if they decide that it's
not fine, then it's a problem.
But that like living in that
fuzzy area where we'd like to
invest something earlier than
before it's a huge problem
becomes a weird thing
because saying like, well,
this could be an all or
nothing situation if we are
non-compliant is not really something
that I've had a lot
of success bringing up to
prioritizing those projects.
- So
I want to make sure
I understand your question. So, obviously,
anything that's like a question
of legal compliance is just
like, yeah, I got do it.
WOMAN: Well, sometimes, we
get documentation from
government partners or
regulatory agencies.
That's like, hey,
these are proposed changes.
We don't know if we're
going to lock these in yet,
but it could happen.
We could decide when we release the
final version of this to do this.
And so you have a six-month
window where you've got to size
up what
that difference is.
- OK, so I understand
this better now.
And I'm sorry if my
answer sounded pedantic before. I
was hoping it would lead
into something more. But
so if there's this potential thing
that could happen is what you're saying.
WOMAN: Yeah.
JOE: That could impact
you, OK. So, again,
I find this Bayesian idea
of an expected loss really helpful.
OK, and this is when--
yeah, you don't know.
The future is uncertain. You
don't know what's going to
happen. But there's some
probability it's going to happen,
and there's a range of
penalties or losses you could
incur if it does happen.
And a real simple example is
that if there's a 10% chance
you're going to lose a dollar,
you're expected loss is 10%
of a dollar or 10 pennies,
versus a 90% chance you're
going to lose a dollar.
That's a 90 cent
expected loss. And so
I think given that uncertainty,
it's not a question of
like breaking the law,
but your question
is around like, oh,
we don't know if there's going
to be these regulations in the
future. How much
might this impact us?
I think this expected
loss framework can really help
support rational decision
making in an uncertain future,
rather than always jumping to
the most extreme worst case
scenario, which is not an
optimal way to make decisions.
Yeah.
RACHAEL: I want to echo
what somebody said in the chat,
and it's a phone number, so
I don't know who it is. But
it does seem like we're
discussing different, and they
said, and equally important
methods of establishing ROI.
And I'm realizing that as
well that I think, in my head,
I always thought of like ROI as
like you have to come up with
this accounting number and the actual
number that it's going to
impact in terms of revenue versus
thinking of the statistical
side of things as well. So
it's really interesting.
- There was a good question
in the chat, Rachael,
about how to handle when
your project underperforms relative to projections.
- Yeah, I was going to have JT
asked that one live. JT, if
you want to jump in here.
- Yeah, sorry if my
treadmill was a little loud. I
don't have my headphones
in right now.
DEREK: No, we can't hear
it. We can't hear it.
JT: Cool.
- And shout out to the cats
who code t-shirt, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
- Yeah, I
guess I was just wondering how
you handle if a project
that you've had to pitch
and sort of fight for,
how you handle if maybe
it under-delivers or
underperforms, as you said.
Mostly, I guess I'm wondering
about the trust aspect of
like the decision
makers or stakeholders,
how that impacts any future
proposals you have for projects.
- So
you got to remember, A, there's
variability in the world.
And B, you can't
control everything.
And the thing you can control
though is transparency.
And so I think that's
just really key that, one,
your findings--
so your ROI projections
should reflect a range
to begin with.
I mean,
even just mean and interval is
like a great anchor point of
just to remind them. We
don't know the future with certainty.
This is the reasonable range
of outcomes we might expect.
And then just to be transparent
throughout about how you--
without drowning
them in detail.
But just be transparent
about how you arrived at your
numbers, and then what
you saw at end of
season. I mean,
there have certainly
been projects, even successful
projects, that have been on
that along the way fell short
because we
were unaware of
some key factor.
And then you learn because
it doesn't deliver the way that
you expected it to.
And
never during that did I feel
like the leaders who had
invested in us were upset
or frustrated. It was like,
look, we leaned into
a difficult problem,
and we learned along the way.
And just be clear about it.
This was what we overlooked.
This is the correction we put in
place as we pursue it next time.
And I think that
that transparency
and honesty is
the most you can do.
But again, just also
anchor them to a--
just get them thinking ahead of
time about there's a range of
outcomes we could experience even
if we did introduce this
through improvement
of 1% or 2%.
It's sampling variation. It
could show up in our customer sample
for the year as a lot of
different values. That's
not how normal people think.
Normal people think
very causally, narratively, precisely.
They don't think in terms of
variance. So you have to condition
your
key stakeholders to
expect that kind of variance.
And they'll appreciate
it in my experience.
- I wanted to remind everybody,
if you do want to provide some
perspective here, too, and
weigh in on what you're doing,
feel free to raise your hand just
so I know to call on you.
It's in the Zoom bar below
if you click on reactions.
You'll have a raise
hand. Sorry, Derek.
- No worries. That's great.
So to the under-deliver part,
this is probably going to be
very different to what Joe said, too.
But we have maybe like four
different ways in which we can
expect and/or watch
potential or actual
under-delivered
projects. So early in our
baseline, trying to establish
what the effects
really might be.
If it looks like it's not
quite as big of say an issue
or feasible
for us to pursue it, and
we suspect it would be
something that under-delivers
on the potential impact,
we're not going to do it.
During model building, if we
do not cross certain acceptable
thresholds in particular things around like
precision recall or PBV and NPV,
we have some deployments
like do not miss.
You just absolutely do
not miss a prediction.
If the models aren't
performing well enough,
we will not go forward with it,
which seems probably pretty typical.
But then, we get into
a little bit later where
say in kind of like an
earlier silent deployment,
we can watch
things for a while,
be very cautious and safe
for some of our stuff.
And think Chloe's here so she
can definitely jump in and talk
a lot about this
for some of the work we do.
And sorry if this kind of
gets a little maybe ML-opsy,
but we have two types
of monitoring we do.
One is we monitor models,
and we monitor the intervention.
So the model may target one
thing while its use is meant to
impact something else.
And those are the primary
metrics that I showed.
If we're not seeing, say,
an actual impact or something is
going in the wrong direction.
That for us is under-deliver, and
you just stop.
So we are also carefully
watching the intended
intervention metrics here,
which is the primary metrics of what
you're going to change in the hospital.
And fortunately,
we don't really have
anything that under-delivers because we
do, like Joe
said, we understand variability.
Things are very weird,
especially just a smidgen
outside or still within the
pandemic in health care.
Things are all over the place.
But
we've been talking a lot about
this in the context of one of
our particular projects where
in the--
or in the post phase, it's
been deployed. It's being used,
made a big impact,
dropped readmission rates.
And we're seeing over time,
it's drifting back up.
So we have this really,
really uncomfortable
question right now.
What if we pull it, does
everything just jump back up,
or is this a natural trend
back up where something about the
deployment a year
later is not quite
actually working?
So, yeah, we have to
start thinking about this.
We didn't really under-deliver,
but we're starting
to lose some ground.
And we don't know
if it's actually
what we did or if
it's something bigger,
which is probably the case
within an exhausted health care
system, where readmission rates are
just kind of up in general.
So this is actually a super
tricky for us because we're at
a point where we
need to figure out.
As the direction of an intervention
is kind of losing some ground,
what do we do?
- I'm thinking also, as
we talk about this that--
we mentioned earlier,
those metrics that your stakeholders
all align on and value,
I'm thinking also about just
explicitly redefining those metrics in
some cases is often really valuable.
And this goes to
that underperformance issue is that
two people can mean completely
different things by the same metric.
And
if you both
explicitly defined it,
and then thought
ahead about what
are potential ways where--
I like Derek's
monitoring question--
or monitoring answer a
lot. Like what are things--
what are ways
things can go awry,
and how can you
get ahead of that?
So like you think about
A/B testing or experimentation and
science. Like,
science really cares
about false positives.
They don't want false positive
effects getting into that body of
scientific knowledge.
I think that's a lot less
important in industry.
It matters in medicine,
so I'm going to--
I'll say to Derek case,
this is not his approach.
But if you think about
in tech, a lot of times,
a false positive
is a free mistake.
All the development costs are sunk
by the time that the test runs.
If you release some minor
change that turns out to be
like a false positive result,
no one's harmed by this.
It's actually the false
negatives in tech that are
really dangerous.
And those are not
the priority in statistical significance
testing in other areas.
The reason I'm bringing
all this up is like,
so I work on experimentation.
Things that I get--
metrics that matter to me
and my stakeholders are like
accuracy and
duration or speed.
So like, well, what's accuracy?
Is accuracy avoiding false
positives? They're free mistakes?
Or can I redefine accuracy
as like some kind of optimization
rate that's focused more
on detecting true effects than
avoiding false effects?
That kind of shift,
accuracy is like a term we
can all throw around. But
you could completely redefine
that and justifiably.
But you need to get your
stakeholders on board that, hey, look,
we're not going to key
your index on false positive rates.
That's not what matters
to us as a business.
And again,
if you've explicitly addressed that
up front, and you say, look,
I think we could have better
business performance by
shifting our focus toward
true positives rather than avoiding
these false positives.
And then again,
you do all your simulations
to show why you've got
a promising way to pursue this.
But you just admit up front.
We're going to have
more false positives.
And we're OK with that because
those are free mistakes in our
area. Those are not free
mistakes in medicine.
Those are not free mistakes
in a lot of other areas.
But in many areas
of tech, they are.
So,
yeah,
just kind of thinking in
advance about what are ways
that things could go awry
or get misinterpreted.
And then making sure that you
have the tracking system in place,
which is also just all going
to come key at the end of the
project when you have to show
how did things you
know materialize in real life.
- Yeah, definitely. And Dan,
I see you have something
to add to this topic, too.
You want to jump in?
- Yeah, although it might
be changing the subject a little
bit. So I don't want to
change if that's not
what you want to do.
- Oh, that's OK.
But does anybody else feel
like this conversation could go on
for three hours about?
I feel like there's so
much to talk about here.
- Yeah, no,
sorry, I'm battling
a cold, too.
I feel like I'm the
only non-data scientist on the phone.
So the conversation about Bayesian
statistics is a little bit--
oh, good. Thanks, Rachael,
make me feel good here.
The things that I'm thinking
about are maybe a little bit
more fundamental.
I think what Derek and Joe
are talking about are really
high level. I mean, this
is like professional.
I know, Joe, you said
you'd never been taught this, but
I feel like you could
teach the class on it.
The things that I think about--
- Had to learn something
in just 10 years.
DAN: Yeah, exactly.
What I think about this
is, what does the company need?
And think Derek's
example that he showed was just
so perfect of this. Because
like, it didn't do it on
purpose, or it did it on
purpose, but it wasn't like in
your face. But it was like,
these are the metrics the
company actually cares about.
How is what you're doing
fixing those metrics?
So I think what we get a lot,
what I tend to see is
passionate data scientists. And
they're going off, and they
see stuff, and they're like, oh,
I bet I could do this.
But it doesn't come from this
direct line from strategy.
So I love Derek's
presentation of it because it's like,
tell me where it is here.
So I think that is--
if we had to take one
thing away from it,
I would love to take that away.
- Yeah, no, 100% agree.
Put it in the metrics
that your non-technical stakeholders care about.
Yeah, which is probably
not area under the curve.
It's like live saved,
empty beds, et cetera. Yeah,
just put it in those terms.
And the data scientists
will be compelled, too.
so let's just go for
that lowest common denominator for persuasion.
- And then my next point
that I'll get off my soapbox here.
But my next point was, why
are they asking about ROI?
And sometimes,
they ask about ROI because
it's a multi-billion dollar decision,
and so the CFO needs
to know. And so
100%, you need to
go dig into this.
But I think sometimes
they ask about ROI
because they don't
think it's valuable.
And they're just asking you,
prove your value on this.
And then, I think, sometimes, there
are projects that are devoid
of any kind of corporate
metrics or anything like
that. And so they're saying,
what's the value? So you can
do all the work you want,
you're never going
to convince them.
So you got to pull it back
to strategy somehow and bring that forward.
- I guess don't see those as--
I don't see those as competing.
Like, if you have a strategy,
a good strategy should be
anchored to a clear goal.
And then the company,
your leaders,
are aligning resources to ensure
the successful pursuit of that goal.
I guess, I
don't see the conflict at all.
DAN: No, that's right. The
conflict is with your--
it sounded like your
organizations are very structured.
And I think maybe some of
the sciencey organizations,
it's a little bit looser,
and so you get a
little bit more
exploration. And that that's
not very easy to tie back
directly to strategy by--
- This is a good point.
This is a good point.
Some things are like--
I can think around like,
skill development among the
data scientists and analysts.
It's something where it's,
intuitively, it's like, yeah,
if we invest in this,
this should pay dividends.
That will be very,
very hard to measure.
But it's like--
or the best measurement you're
going to get is probably
anecdotes and case studies. But
is it still worth doing?
Yes, but again,
you're going to have to be
transparent up front. That it's like,
we're not going to be able
to measure this with x
percent increase conversions
or decrease mortalities.
But it's like, where do
the moonshot ideas come from? Again,
it kind of depends on--
you have to know your
leadership and what do they
have appetite for?
If
they have some like
visionary bandwidth where they're willing
to float some of
those moonshot--
education's a moonshot idea.
But if they're willing
to entertain some of those
less clear investments, good.
I think you could frame it
as part of a good investment portfolio.
DAN: Yeah.
- But, yeah, you
can't measure those
things nearly as easily.
So it's harder to sell.
- Thank you. My point
was just to say that
the people trying to do those
moonshots might get a lot of
questions about ROI, might do as much
work as they can, and still never
make it. So
when you get those questions,
I think it's just worth thinking,
why are they asking me this?
How do we position this? Is
it possible to convince them?
- OK.
-
Something I thought might be
helpful to add to is sometimes
they're not asking for the ROI.
You might be sharing what you
think the potential ROI is to
help push your
own idea forward,
and that they're not
necessarily asking you what's
the specific ROI of this.
And that's something that
I've been thinking
about a lot lately.
Like when I have an idea for
something, and I want to go run
to share it with our
leadership team like putting together the
business case for that and
explaining this is why I think
this is a good idea.
Here's the examples where
this has come up, or--
and I know one other non-data
scientist that I saw was
listening in, is our
president here at Posit,
and he's often one of the people
that I go to with some of these
ideas. So, Tareef,
if I was wondering if you
had anything you wanted to add to
the conversation to?
- It's interesting. I
mean, I think both Joe
and Dan raised really important
points here. I like to
ask myself the question,
what are the underlying
assumptions behind anything
that we're doing?
Whether it's on the
strategy level, what
is the end goal here?
And then how do I know
that I'm on the right path?
That being said,
you also want to leave enough
space for the moonshots.
But I challenge everybody when they
say, hey, I want to do x.
I'm like, why? And what are
the metrics that you are hoping to
drive? It's interesting when
you show the intake form.
It's intriguing because that is
an existing system that you have.
The question that I find
myself asking is well, OK,
how long does it take before you
know that you've got a good test, and
when does the impact
sort of kick in? Because
like in product development
for us when we're building new
features or new products or
whatnot, it could take 18 months,
24 months before you know
whether that investment was a
good investment or not.
But
I think it's good discipline
in general to say, hey,
you know what? Here's what
I'm assuming is going to change,
or here's what I'm assuming
is going to get better.
Here's how I'm
going to measure it.
And
then use that as a way
to learn and get better.
That's sort of my
instinct on it.
The moonshot one
is a good question.
I think you might want to be
OK with saying, hey, 5% to
10% of all the investments that
I make are going to be these
kinds of moonshots, and I'm OK
if they fall flat on their face.
JJ and I do that pretty regularly
when we say, hey, you know what?
We're going to take a crack at X
or Y or Z, and we'll make an
investment that we're
like, if it fails,
it's not going to kill
the company. But if it succeeds,
could sort of generate
a lot more revenue.
So I don't know if that's
what you were looking for from me,
Rachael. But I push Rachel
pretty hard when she's like,
I've got seven ideas. I'm
like, great, which one matters?
-
There was a comment earlier
about your personal time
investment, and
this echoed me was--
so I used to build furniture.
That was like before
I was in tech.
And estimating how long a new
piece of furniture was going to
take was really hard.
And so when I took really good
notes, what I learned was this, that if
I'd built something
similar before,
I had to triple my estimate.
And if I hadn't built
anything similar before,
I had to multiply times nine.
And friends would say like, oh,
you're terrible at doing
estimates. And I'd be like, no,
I'm awesome at doing estimates.
And then when I
got to grad school,
I found that the mechanical
engineers had names for this.
They called it the rule of pi,
that everything takes 3.14 times
longer than you remember it taking.
And so the point of all
this was just as you think about
your own time investment,
you've done all the ROI,
but just making sure you
have bandwidth to see this through
successfully. If you've done
something really similar
before, triple it.
If you've never done
something similar before,
multiply times nine. And
I can tell you on my
own projects, usually,
that ninefold thing is just like
all the stuff you didn't think of.
Like, OK, you put the
model into production, well, now,
you need to train every
relevant user you need to build
an enormous amount of
documentation an enormous
amount of tracking.
This is all the stuff that
was not part of the model
development. And
if you don't have
time for it, well,
your life's going to be really
miserable for the rest of the
year while you're working
nights and weekends to see it
through, or just budget,
really over budget for time,
and you can have a happy life
and get things going.
- I just want to add one
more thing to what you just said,
Joe. I love this.
I'm going to think about
this pi squared idea.
But the
other thing that I think
is really important is to just
remember that the more
things you take on simultaneously,
the more your work in
progress increases,
the more your
context switching.
And things will
actually take longer
than you even realize.
So
I know this is kind of like
meat and potatoes for a lot of
people, but it's so easy to
get sucked in and say, oh,
this is not going to take long.
I'll do this. I'll do this.
Before you know it, you're
doing 17 things at the same
time. And that just slows
the living daylights out of you.
- This hour goes by very
quickly here. But I know if
people have to run at
the top of the hour,
that's OK. Thank
you for joining us.
But I'm going to stay on and
hang out if people want to keep
talking, too. But Brian, I saw
you had your hand raised, too,
and if you want to jump in.
- Yeah, so, I mean,
I come at this--
so early on my career,
I was actually in charge
of doing projects like this and
actually presenting them
as budget items for the
coast guard to Congress.
And you get your ass grilled.
And so,
for instance,
when I ran a data science
team and insurance company,
all of our projects were ROI.
The goal of this project is
to shave X percent off this cost
it's worth X. Here
are all the variables.
These are what we
think the ranges are.
This is a project we should do.
And the way we engage our
team to trace point, yes,
when you multitask,
you're really in trouble.
We always had a--
every team member had a
short project, the quick and easy,
the medium project,
and the long project.
Because in the long project,
which means there was going
to be time for stakeholders to
make decisions and do stuff.
And they don't turn around on
a dime. So you have a midpoint,
and you do a presentation.
You're not going
to hear anything,
feedback for two
or three weeks.
That's when you can
work on other stuff.
On a financial basis,
I always just do stuff as
what we call real options.
Your first is your exploratory
POC. What's that going to cost?
What's the benefit? Benefits
probably close to zero,
but it's going to be
an investment cost.
But then you have an option
to kill, an option to expand,
or an option to
do something else.
And if you can think about
some of those options,
you can price them out.
And so I had to present all
my projects. Five years,
here's
the discounted value.
Here's the return. Because
I had to go through this
CIO, who went to the CFO,
and that's how they
looked at things.
I want to buy
ISAAC Connect,
and it's cost me X amount
of bucks a year for a license.
These are the benefits
I'm going to get from it.
These are the amount of
people that I'm going to have.
It's going to cost me X
amount of person, all these things.
And so I'd have these
presentations to people,
and you could go through
those discussions. And
we would do variable
sensitivity,
goes back to that never present
a point estimate.
It's a range between
this and that.
It's a range between X and
Y. And if you get really fancy,
you can actually convolve them
all in a simulation and say,
here is the entire
range of outcomes,
and this is what it looks like. No,
it's not a bell curve. It never is.
RACHAEL: Yeah.
- But so
when you talk about ROI,
that's how I've always
thought about it.
That's how I've always been
forced to present it though.
Because if I'm asking
my division leader, president, whoever
to spend 50, 75, or 100
grand, or to dedicate--
you think about a man, a person
hours, 2,000 hours a year,
maybe I want to dedicate 1,000
hours of the day to scientists
that cost me X amount of money.
What am I going
to get for that?
And that's just
some of the ways that I've had
to present it and pitch it and
get people to sign off and
say yes, we will give you the
money, or we will give
you the time to do that.
And to the earlier point,
it's all about what metrics.
What are you going to improve?
You're either going to improve
revenue or cut costs or improve
efficiency with cut cost.
You have to have that
in mind. Otherwise, it's just R&amp;D.
And if it's just R&amp;D, then,
you got to be able to
pitch that to, hey, this is R&amp;D.
We don't have anything for it.
But we aren't going into
space that we've never been before.
And sometimes, you got
to be honest with that.
- Yeah, well, maybe while
we're on the insurance example here, I want
to jump over to Adam's question
in the chat.
If you're still on, Adam.
- Oh, yeah, this could
be a real rabbit hole.
So we're almost at time.
I don't want to keep anybody.
But yeah, I think the question
is we were talking earlier about
this idea, false positives
and true positives.
And like in a
classification problem,
you can kind of tune that,
and you kind of associate costs
and things to those various outcomes.
Yeah, so in insurance, I'm
in property and casualty
insurance. And we work on
models that go into pricing,
and it's way more complicated
than just sort of true and
false positives. We
build a pricing model.
We try to estimate losses
for a given set of features.
And then what happens is
that all that information kind of
goes over the wall to
actuarial partners.
Our product partners who have
certain kinds of business
objectives, they have to hit.
So, actually, the models kind
of get tweaked and modified.
And then they layer
in additional things like
discounts and so forth. And so
when I go in thinking about,
OK, I want to
improve these models.
Maybe I'm bringing in a new
third party data source, for example.
I want to figure out if this
is a worthwhile data source to include.
I have to figure out
is the model improving?
But then I have to know
also is it worth buying?
And so the model is kind of
decoupled in some ways from the
final outcomes in
really complex ways.
And I'm wondering if there's
some way to think about this
fuzzy sort of connection
between model improvement and
ROI at the end of the
day. It's a long winded explanation, but--
- No,
I think a lot of decisions
get made on overly simple metrics
just because it's
so overwhelming. Like
not all customers produce
the same amount of value,
but so many business decisions
are based exclusively on
conversion and retention as
though every customer were
equally valuable.
So but
you're going to overwhelm
your stakeholders if you're simultaneously
introducing a new justification
for like, oh, well,
deduct these costs, add these
lifetime value benefits, et cetera.
DAN: Exactly.
- Those have to become
separate issues.
So then,
you just have this reliable
lifetime value metric you could
pull off the shelf. And
you could ask now, hey,
what if we made decisions
based on three-year revenue per
customer rather
than raw conversion,
which treats everyone
as equally valuable?
How much more money
would we save?
would we make?
Those are all kind of
your ways to shape ROI,
by redefining the
question. I don't know,
maybe that was kind of a
theme today was actually just like,
you are in a very
powerful position to redefine the
question when
you're doing an ROI
investigation and don't
take that lightly.
But
keep in mind that people
only have so much attention.
So you got to modularize things
so that they can stay on board.
I see so many data
science projects just completely overwhelm
their stakeholders.
So avoid that, and
yeah, you can get a
lot of influence from that, so.
- Jerod, I know you
had your hand raised.
So I know we're
right at time here,
but just wanted to see if
you had time to ask your question.
JEROD: Oh, I just wanted
to make a comment about these
moonshot ideas and
these R&amp;D ideas.
We usually
at the beginning of the year
just agree upon an amount of
time that you have
to do research
for projects that don't
necessarily have an immediate impact.
And
then basically,
throughout the year,
if you come across a new really
cool thing that you want to work on,
the
question immediately
bounces back to you.
Is this worth stopping
the other research that you're
doing right now and
switch to the new project?
Can you wrap it
up can you switch?
Because you only
have so much time.
And then there is not
even a need to generate
a return on that investment.
And then,
usually,
I can, myself,
answer the question whether
I want to switch or not.
Because I either don't want to
give up on the project that I'm
working on, or I'm done
with the previous project.
Hope that helps them.
- Well, I don't want to
keep you, Derek and Joe, too long.
So thank you so much for
sharing your insights and experience here.
I just want to see if you
had anything else you wanted to add
to the conversation
before we go.
- It's hard.
Good luck, everyone.
- Just give it 10 years, and
it'll be a no-brainer. No, this is great
participation. Thanks,
everybody. This was good.
- Yeah, this was awesome. I
would love to keep having these
conversations. And I mean, I
will definitely stick around here, but
I understand people have to go
to other meetings and can
only spend so much
time with us. But
is this something we'd like to
keep talking about,
or if there are other specific topics
we want to do a deep dive on?
Please let me know in the chat.
Or if you have an idea later,
you can message me on
LinkedIn or email me.
I'll just put my
email in here, too.
Awesome. Thank you all so much.
JOE: Yeah. Thanks, everybody.
DEREK: Thank you.
- I know there were a few
great questions that we didn't get to cover.
So maybe I'll go and kind of
collect one of those or some of those.
But Derek, if you
are able to stay on,
I saw one of the
questions was about
the infrastructure
cost, I believe.
I think David Sluiter
asked this maybe.
How does the production
resource cost,
like cloud computing factor
into your ROI calculations?
- Here's an easy answer
on the cloud computing.
Given that we're in a hospital
and in Canada with very
particular regulations,
we don't use the cloud. So
the infrastructure stuff
becomes part of operational
budgets that we talk about in
the beginning of the year with
everyone else, including
IT and other folks of,
yeah, if you want
these projects to keep going,
this is where you get to
point to your previous ROI.
Do you want projects that
will continue to bring down costs
and bring down readmissions
and increase patient flow?
This is the
infrastructure we need.
These are the
subscriptions we need.
Fortunately or unfortunately,
we're entirely on prem.
So I don't need to
talk about cloud.
- For anybody who decided
to hang around here,
do you have any other
last pressing questions?
[INAUDIBLE], apologies for
mispronouncing your name.
I saw you shared a
framework in the chat,
and was wondering if you'd be open
to sharing a little bit about that.
And no worries if I'm
putting anybody on the spot.
I'll try and go through the
chat and pull out some of those
resources there.
Awesome. Well, thank you all
so much for joining today.
This was a really fun
lively conversation. I really appreciate it.
DEREK: Thanks again.
RACHAEL: Have a great rest
of the day, everybody.
I'll see you later. Bye.
DEREK: Bye.